why is storytelling important it should
be entertaining but it should nourish
your soul in the same way one of the
great books of all time could do the
beauty of Storytelling in a cinematic
and Sonic form it reaches you on every
level on a cellular level it can really
be therapeutic you can learn so much
about yourself if I can have movies do
that take people on Journeys or
adventures in a story to get them to
that state of mind today I want to make
movies that lead us to the State of Mind
of feeling that there's Faith we're
grounded by faith it's not religion it's
it's just Faith abiding by the Golden
Rule you know it's all those things
about one-on-one human connection